[Music]
oh
chris we're live thank you very much
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome my name is
chris leslie the director of resources
and in the absence of a chairman and
vice chairman
by an opening proceedings this afternoon
in a moment i will call for nominations
for chairman of this meeting
members before we proceed can you please
ensure your
videos and microphones are turned off
can i now ask any member wishing to
nominate
the position of chairman for this
meeting to please
unmute your microphone turn on your
video
and state your name and nomination
councillor none would like to nominate
councillor mark hurd for this meeting
i'd like to second there
thank you i have a nomination and i have
councillor
seconding given
there are no other nominations
could i ask members please record your
vote please mr leslie
can we do a recorded vote and we need
members
uh to vote on that uh yes of course
members um as normal i'm going to call
the names out alphabetically
if you could just indicate if you're for
against or abstaining
i'm starting with councillor bamford
please
um tara i think it needed to be seconded
the um request for a recorded vote i
don't
know that anybody seconded that all
right i'll second that
canceler all right but i i'm
i'm fine with that thank you
uh councillor bassinger
agreed thank you very much councillor
miss beale
okay she's online hey
councillor brian beale
councillor bell yes agreed
thank you councillor boyce great
thank you councillor durham
chancellor edwards agreed thank you
councillor mrs fleming agreed thank you
councillor fluker greed thank you
councillor herd
um i feel i should abstain from this
thank you very much
councillor helm agreed thank you
councillor hull
thank you very much councillor jarvis
agreed thank you cancer
agree tara thank you
he'll be under apologies i'm afraid he
he cut he can't
oh i'm sorry he's not qualified to vote
because he wasn't in attendance the
first time round so he isn't here thank
you
thank you very much castle morris four
thank you very much councillor nunn
thank you councillor stamp or
stilts or
cancer swain poor thank you castles
thompson and councillor miss white
and the result of that vote is 21-4
nobody against and one abstention thank
you very much
thank you um for that tara i will now
hand over
to councillor heard
thank you mr leslie and thank you
members
for your confidence in me to chair
this meeting um members this is another
opportunity
to hear these applications and
i hope in full uh this meeting is a
continuation
of last thursday's abandoned meeting
and i will be relying on rule 8
and rule 10 of our constitution
for good order i feel i should refer
to last week's meeting briefly where
derogatory comments were made against
some officers i do not support
these comments
so good afternoon and welcome to this
special district planning meeting today
on thursday
the 20th of august 2020.
my name is councillor mark hurd and as
you've just seen
i am i have been appointed chairman
for this meeting uh this meeting is held
under new regulations which come into
effect on the
4th of april in response to the covid
19 situation and there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all could i please ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure that your microphone remains
muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting you are given
your consent to being recorded members
and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function
should not be used for any other purpose
please do not use the raise hand
function as this is not available on all
member
devices when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting now
if i may
ask officers taking part in the meeting
to introduce themselves
starting with mr dodson
good afternoon members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr dodson mr holmes
good afternoon members i'm richard
holmes structure of service delivery
thank you mr lee
good afternoon members i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place at morning
district council
thank you thank you mr turner
good afternoon members i'm devon herner
specialist in development management
thank you and uh ms matthews
um i'll be representing miss matthews
today
hannah dungay um planning specialist
service delivery
thank you hannah uh mr crouch
simon quelch and i'm the lead legal
specialist and monitoring officer
thank you very much very much uh and ms
bird
good afternoon tara bird committee
services officer thank you
thank you tara please could ask any
other officers to
identify themselves
good afternoon members jordina button
bradley a program lead
okay thank you georgina
tara could i please ask you now to carry
out a roll call
uh calling the members in alphabetical
order
uh yes chairman members if you could
just indicate when your name's called if
you're in attendance please
i'm starting with councillor bamford
please yes i'm here tara thank you
cancer bastinger i'm present tara
thank you councilman
councillor brian beale
councillor bell present tara
cancer voice yeah thank you
councillor durham
edwards present tara thank you
councillor mrs fleming
present thank you council fluker
present
thank you cancer keys
cancel the keys um
apologies from counselor kickstarter
this is thompson apologies from council
of keys please i believe he was away
last time so
wouldn't be eligible to vote anyway
thank you okay thank you councillor
jarvis
president thank you tara cancer lagan
present thanks tara maze
present tara thank you
uh casa morris
good afternoon everybody thank you
councillor nun
uh present tara thank you councillor
seancy
present tara thank thank you councillor
good afternoon tara present good
afternoon
councillor schemes president tara thank
you thank you
councillor stamp president thank you
cancer stilts
good afternoon sarah present council
swain
mr president tara thank you councillor
mrs thompson
president thank you and councillor miss
white
that's the attendance thank you chairman
um thank you to our agenda
item number two is uh apologies for
absence so
may i have the apologies for abstinence
please tara
uh yes chairman um apologies have been
received from
councillor mrs channer councillor dewitt
councillor harker
councillor keys and councillor morley
thank you chairman
thank you very much chairman can i can i
just say that
um ann beale gave her apologies to me
thank you thank you councillor is that
noted tara
yes that's noted thank you chairman
thank you very much
agenda item number three declaration of
interest this is to disclose the
existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs
six to eight inclusive of a code of
conduct
for members the members are reminded
that they're also required to disclose
any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the chat function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
tara can you advise if any member has
indicated a wish to speak please
yes chairman so far i've got four
members councillor fluker
councillor nunn councillor mays
councillor lagan
and uh councillor schemes as well
chairman thank you
thank you very much uh i'll take those
in that order then councillor fluker
yeah thank you chairman uh agenda item
eight i've got a perceived
bias an agenda item nine i missed part
of the debate previously so i can't take
part
in any of those items so i shall be
leaving the meeting now thank you
chairman
thank you very much councillor none
thank you chairman um item uh eight
uh knowles farm uh like some of the rest
of you i'm sure i've received
correspondence from the developer
uh so uh this is declaring the receipt
of that correspondence non-petunia
and item nine uh bradwall i've received
um
a number of emails from uh individual
parties
interested in the bradford situation
again non-petunia
thank you very much
thank you councillor none councillor
maze
thank you mr chairman i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest in item
eight um as i know uh the owner of uh
psalm of the land uh at noel's farm and
also
like councillor nun i've received some
correspondence from
the developer um item number
nine non-pecuniary as i said on the
working group and i've also received
emails and some letters regarding
bradwell b thank you
thank you councilman's councillor lagan
thank you chair yeah very similar to my
colleagues item number eight
non-pecuniary received uh
correspondence from the developer and
also gender item nine bradwell
have also been in conversation and
meetings
and receive a significant number of
emails
regarding this development non-pecuniary
chair thank you
thank you councillor councillor schemes
hello yes sir item nine bradwell b i
i'm also in receipt of a correspondence
non-pecuniary
and i think i should declare that i'm
part of the working group i'm not sure
whether that's necessary but i do it
every time
and nobody says it isn't so i better
carry on doing it thank you
thank you very much tara are there any
other um
decorations i'm just sharing i've got a
few more
and councillor shawnee council morris
wishes to raise a point of clarification
and then also councillors fleming
bassinger and belle chairman
chairman also me i haven't got the check
function cancellation
i keep asking to speak chairman and i'm
not getting acknowledged is anything
coming from when i'm asking to speak to
him and it's cancer stamp
twice now i'd like to say yeah
that's the first time i've heard from
you counselor stan
yes i've been using the chat function
chairman which is what you asked me to
do but i'm being ignored
i'm just going through the list through
the list now i will add your name to the
list
thank you and and me councillor edwards
please
chairman so i have you on there so uh
councillor shawna see first please
uh thank you chairman um yes item eight
non-pecuniary um as i also um
as a lot of counsellors have had
correspondence from the developer
and i also am known to one of the
objectors
um on this item and item nine
um brb um many
emails relating um to this
um as well thank you chairman
thank you councillor sean c councillor
morris you have a point of clarification
thank you very much chair i uh would
just like to
request to know whether or not the
um part that is intended to go into pnc
will actually be
voted on because uh myself and uh quite
a few residents
are very concerned that uh we might be
bullied
in private and would obviously like to
see exactly what's going on
as i would like them to see as well so i
would just uh
seek a um confirmation from yourself
that uh we will have a recorded vote
about whether or not we receive uh this
report in
prop pnc private confidential because i
think the people have a right to know
what we're going to be threatened with
okay thank you for that i can confirm
that we will be having a vote
um it will be a recorded vote if
requested
and seconded and by any other member
i've just requested it okay thank you
um i will second that council bell
thank you um i have um
i've got a sorry i can't read my writing
here i've got counsellor bass but
somebody else uh
said that they would like to declare
after that can you help me tara
cancer filling chairman councillor flynn
sorry
thompson please thank you council
fleming
thank you chair um item nine just to
declare that i won't be able to take
part in the debate
or vote because i missed part of the
debate due to connection problems last
time
thank you thank you very much councillor
passenger
thank you mr chairman um item eight uh i
received correspondence
item nine i am sitting on the um
brb working group so non-pecuniary for
both thank you
thank you very much councillor bell
um yes apologies for no camera um chair
i'm having some bandwidth issues so
i'm slightly confused everybody as far
as i know has received some
correspondence around item nine
as uh all counts all members have been
included but
as others are declaring um in the
interests of open source openness and
transparency i suppose i must declare as
well also
so that would be non non-pecuniary item
nine
thank you thank you very much councillor
edwards
yes uh chairman thank you uh item eight
and non-pecuniary i have met with the
developer although
some years ago on paris business
but i also have received the letter item
nine i have also received emails
regarding
brb thank you chairman thank you very
much
councillor stamp
thank you apparently my chat's not
working chairman so i don't know how you
want to deal with this two things
i i'm not going to declare any
non-particular interest because we all
get
emails from residents and everybody else
regarding planning applications
and unless the council decide that we
have to i think it's a total waste of
time
the second thing chairman is i wasn't
attending last week's meeting
does that preclude me or exclude me from
anything to do with
today's meeting i was present at the
first initial
um hearings and applications uh three
weeks ago or four weeks ago
am i entitled to to still participate on
this one please
i'm sure i am but just for clarity thank
you chairman
thank you councillor stamp i think we
only had one item of business which was
completed and we hadn't quite started on
the other but i will
uh ask mr quelch to confirm that thank
you
yes councillor stamp is right chairman
of course she can participate because
there was no
we did not get to those two other
matters yeah
okay thank you thank you very much thank
you very much
um councillor stilts thank you mr
chairman
um like everybody else non-pecunery
nonpacunary8n9 because
we all receive this correspondence but
also
as i am a modern south
uh councillor as well
thank you very much uh councillor
thompson
uh thank you again apologies for no
camera i similarly have uh bandwidth
issues on and off and i wouldn't like to
lose my connection
um i until the very beginning of this
week i was a member of the brb working
group thank you i was there and
uh as part of a position not as a name
so that i'm no longer i believe
thank you thank you very much and tara
can i just confirm that i've also
received correspondence in relation to
uh gender item 8 and 9 but it's a game
non-vicunary
um councillor helm
sorry mr chairman i've had to date this
way i'm a member of the uh
thank you i'm grateful thank you for
those
members who cannot use the chat function
i think it might be better just to
switch a camera on briefly and then i'll
be able to see
that you need to speak and uh perhaps we
can utilize that
are there any other members who wish to
make a declaration
counselor schemes can i just ask a
question through the chair of simon
quelch
about the um about this this uh
uh declaration of interest is it
necessary for us to declare that we're
members of bradwell working group
and is it necessary to declare that
we've had letters
as councillor stamp outlined
thank you mr mr mr quelch
yes i'm glad councillor schemes asked
that question because it is very
relevant
the code of conduct sets out quite
definitively what is a non-pecuniary
interest
and receiving correspondence from
developers
or third parties um
is not a disclosure doesn't does not
give you a non-pecuniary interest
likewise being a part of um a working
group that belongs to the council an
internal work group
likewise does not give you a
non-pecuniary interest
if you were if you were on an outside
body
and there was something relevant to that
then yes that would be
non-pecuniary but not an internal
working group
okay i hope uh hope members
can note that any other declarations
chairman that seems to be everybody
that's indicated on the track function
thank you uh councillor swain
yes thank you chairman um this is in
advance of the next item
which i've taught might be
beneficial now they're actually
legal questions from mr crouch or mr lee
and firstly though i would say if you
read
the actual section referred to um
for exclusion of um under item for when
you read the
section in the um relevant act it seems
to me quite clear
that we do have to take the legal advice
and confidence
um my specific questions which i want to
clarify
might be helpful to other members
one what was the authority for engaging
council
secondly is engaging council considered
to be an operational
issue council swain before weeks before
we move on to that
i just need to go through a couple of
things those questions will be answered
but i'd like to go through the normal
process but i will come to you
well yes i mean they don't really have
an effect on the vote on
uh um item four um but
okay but i i will i will come back i
will come back to you because but before
we move into the private session and i
will defer to the monitoring officer
to take us through the process for the
remainder of the meeting
can i ask the questions then at the
beginning of item 4.
i i just need to speak to the monitoring
officer first i i'm
i'm happy to hear what you've got to say
uh mr crouch
is that all right for councillor swain
to uh
ask his question yes yes i'm happy to
deal with that now
or afterwards whenever you want to
chairman okay well go ahead councillor
swann
okay thank you chairman there were four
questions first
what was the authority for engaging
council secondly
is engaging council considered to be an
operational matter
and bearing in mind that council is
reporting to the
local planning authority is there a
legal distinction between council
and the district council as local
planning
uh and that arising out of that the
question is
to whom is the advice confidential
okay mr crowd thank you chairman
yeah um the authority uh i think that
that the first and second questions
really are the same because it is an
operational second question really
answers the first question
legal advice is can either be given
by me or it can be given by someone
outside
either way it's still legal advice so
it's an operational matter
so officers obviously have the
discretion if they think
that they need some legal advice on a
particular matter that i can be asked to
give it
if i don't feel i have the expertise or
someone of greater weight
than i needs to be instructed then that
advice will be given by an outside
person but it's still legal advice
and so it's inoperational for example
i'm giving you legal advice now
um it's internal the fact that it's
external doesn't change it it's still
legal advice on an operational level
it's just that we need specialist legal
advice sometimes
and we do that all the time you will
have known councillor swain when
for example we were dealing with um
certain contracts which i won't go into
we took outside solicitors advice on
that
we also took council's advice again that
was operational
uh on question um on question
three uh lpa and the council
are they separate the council is the
local planning authority
if that answers that for you
right okay yes thank you and i think
there was a fourth question as well i'm
sorry uh councillor swain
probably answered that then i was asking
to whom it is confidential
that it includes everybody then officers
and members
it is confidential to the council
because the council is the lpa
that's right thank you thank you very
much
um so before i uh before i
move on into uh request
for private session is there anything
else that you wanted to add
mr crouch
chairman would it be helpful if i just
go through
what what is going to be proposed in the
sense
of the the procedure to be followed
um because this is perhaps a little
different from the norm would that be
helpful chairman
yes it would thank you okay the
the proposed procedure is as follows uh
that um members obviously will need
to vote on whether first of all
uh the two pieces of advice on the two
planning applications should be taken
in private and confidential and that
requires members
to in effect in their minds make two
decisions although obviously it's dealt
with in one vote
and the first one is is the information
and respect
of which a cl that this particular
advice is information in respect of
which a claim
to legal professional privilege could be
maintained in legal proceedings
obviously the public inquiry is
a legal proceeding in the sense that it
is set by statute
under section 78 of the town and country
planning act
so it is a forum that adjudicates on
rights
namely planning rights and the second
question that members have to ask
themselves is
if they're satisfied it is information
and respect respect to which a claim to
legal professional privilege
could be maintained is it um
is it in all the circumstances in the
public interest
to maintain the exemption
or is that outweighed by the public
having it having sight
and knowledge of the information so in
other words when members make a vote
they've got to merge those two if
they're satisfied with
question one then they need to go on to
answer
question two the public interest test if
they're not satisfied
on question one in the words is there an
attraction of legal professional
privilege then they don't need to go on
and answer the public interest test
they would obviously therefore vote
against the motion
um so either one of those two tests if
if if both
aren't satisfied then members vote
against the motion
if members are satisfied that it is then
they vote for it
on this i would just really just like to
make one point on this
if members vote against this motion
then that means the legal advice
on one or both depending on the decision
of members because they could separate
them off into the different applications
if they do if members vote
uh that the matter should be heard in
public
legal advice that legal advice is then
available
to the two developers and members
already have site of that legal device
so they know what it says
that advice would therefore be available
to the lawyers
of both applicants
um if members decide to vote in favor of
the motion
the idea then chairman is that
pnc both legal advices will be
considered
on both applications
but then members would come into open
session
and make a decision on
each application in turn
i believe it's knowles farm first and
then it's bradwell
um the decision needs to be made in
public
and members of the public need to see
how people are voting
i hope that clarifies mata's chairman i
think it does thank you very much so
really um members what we what we will
be citing is to
is to receive the legal advice in
private
and then have a an open
discussion uh in relation to that
application okay
so in that case then uh
is there um i've i've had the chat go
off a couple of times
tara i know some couple of people wanted
to speak before we move into private
session
can you assist oh yes chairman
councillor none wishes to ask a question
thank you councillor
[Music]
thank you very much chairman it's a
question for mr quelch actually
um when the external legal party
uh were instructed uh or both
when they were instructed um was it were
they instructed and did they provide the
advice on the basis that it was legally
privileged and that it would be
discussed in canberra
chairman are you happy for me to answer
that
uh if you're if you're satisfied yes i'm
happy to answer that
um they weren't specifically
told this advice will be heard
in private and confidential they were
purely asked for their
advice when the advice
was received it becomes the advice given
to the local authority the local
authority then needs to decide
whether that advice should be available
to the world at large
or whether it should be dealt with
privately
thank you very much thank you thank you
so
uh so then uh i propose that we now move
into
private session and i move that under
section
100 a 4 at the local government act 1972
that the public and press
be excluded from the meeting during
consideration
of the following items of business on
the grounds that it involves
the likely disco disclosure of exempt
information
as defined in paragraph 5 of part 1
of schedule 12a of the act and
that this satisfies the public interest
is that seconded no second that counts
thank you very much
um will we so we'll take a vote on that
yes please chairman there was a request
for recorded vote that was seconded
thank you very much okay we will take
that recorded vote then please tara
and thank you members um i'll call your
names alphabetically if you could just
indicate if you're for against or
abstaining please
i'm starting with councillor bamford
sorry chad can we just
um confirm what we are actually voting
for against it going into a session
a private session or for it going into
private session
thank you yes uh what the the uh the
motion is for us to move into private
session if you agree with that please
say
four and if you do not please say
against councillor schemes
yeah i'm concerned that we haven't
really debated the issues here we've
heard from the monitoring officer which
has been useful
but this is quite an important decision
and
uh especially in connection with
bradwell b uh where there is
there is a concern that advice uh may
may include of course i have no idea
what it includes but it may include
information that we can't
resist because of financial pressures
and that is something
that is definitely if if that is the
case a speculation i admit but a
possible speculation
then we kind of need to know well then
um if
if that is a possibility uh then of it
then my feeling is
that particular piece of information
should be made public to
to to explain the actions of the council
thank you for that um i think i would be
right insane
uh mr quelch that we can receive
this information and we can
speak about
the content of it
am i writing saying the content of it in
open session
uh chairman no if you if members decide
uh that it should be heard in
pnc then the content should not be
discussed
perhaps it might be helpful if i could
just
um answer councillor scheme's point all
members
should have read the legal advice and it
was with the agenda
um and so members should
already be aware of the context of that
advice so
members will know there is no reference
to the financial pressures
that will that that will be put under
there is advice
on what orders could be made
but there is nothing that actually says
the council must not
do this because um it cannot afford it
okay thank you um but chairman members
should all know that because it's
already available to them yes
i understand that tara are there any
other members who want to speak
before we take the vote um yes chairman
um
councillor thompson council jarvis and
council swain have asked to speak
my question has been addressed about the
the legal advice already being in the
pack thank you so
no need to ask thank you very much
councillor jarvis
uh thank you chairman yes i i just
wanted to make the point that i've heard
all those comments it does seem to me to
make common sense for us to
take the legal advice in private session
i think
that seems like the sort of right format
but that doesn't mean the course that
later on
uh when we debate the actual issues in
in sort of public session uh we you know
we can't um
can't comment on those aspects it seems
to me but initially
it's quite clear that this is the usual
practice to take legal advice
uh in private session because it seems
to me wouldn't it wouldn't be it's not
really
um sensible um to essentially give
uh the the applicants uh is our
information that seems to be you know
sort of the wrong thing
uh to do we saw legal advice we should
debate that
privately uh and i just i would just
urge councillors to
follow the advice with regards to that
item thank you chairman
thank you very much councillor swain
briefly please
uh yes thank you chairman um it might be
helpful if
mr quelch could um clarify the situation
that we have
um if even after
the debate on the on the two
applications
we are still in the position where um
the um we refuse one or other
and the officers
would not um support that position
in relation to an appeal um what
position does that put members in
mr
the yes this goes into some extent
there's legal advice so i will
have to be quite circumspect here
um it answering it briefly
it places the local authority and the
offices in an extremely
difficult position
okay so um we've uh we've now got the
um we so we've had the advice uh i'm
i uh the vote has been agreed
have been seconded so tara could you
take the
vote alphabetically if you are for it
going into closed session
you would save four and if you're
against against
thank you tara the chairman just picking
up from the chat function counselor
bells asked a question about taking the
items separately
yes is that seconded
that i'll second that mark thank you
councillor
so that is second is so we'll take the
two of them
um separately so we'll go
uh okay tara over to you
uh thank you chairman so this the first
vote will be in relation to
noel's farm
okay members so starting with councillor
bamford
please
thank you councillor bassinger
four thank you and
councillor bell four
thank you councillor boyce
four
councillor edwards four
thank you councillor fleming four
thank you
i will abstain
thank you councillor jarvis four
thank you flagging
for cancer maize
for cancer morris
abstain
four that's the skeins
four stamp
four
four
thompson paul
as the result of that vote is 19-4
nobody against and two abstentions
thank you very much can we now move on
to uh
the the second part of the advice which
is in relation to
bradwell and uh
the same again please tara yes chairman
members as before if you could just
indicate four against you're abstaining
please
starting with councillor bamford thank
you for
thank you councillor bassinger
against uh
councillor bell against
boyce poor
counselor against
or castle hull
for darvis
four thanks tom thank you cancer lagging
four please tara thank you councillor
mays
four thank you councillor morris
public have a right to know against
thank you very much councillor none
four councillor shaunicy
four councillor siddall
four thank you cancer schemes
i'm going to abstain
four you can't pick and choose that tara
thank you very much cancer stilts
and two abstentions thank you chairman
thank you tara that's exactly what i
make it as well
uh so
i will now ask committee services to
pause the live stream to the public
website
along with the recording of the meeting
members of the public listening to our
live stream i thank you for joining us
we will return in due course to make a
decision
in open session
[Music]
yes gemini confirmed that we are now
back live thank you
thank you very much uh members of the
public listening to our live stream
i thank you for your patience uh this
meeting
is being recompened at
1513 in open session
so we now move to agenda item number
eight
land north and west of knolls farm wick
hill
in malden uh and this is found on pages
45 to 194 and i will now call on the
officer
to present this item miss matthews
please could you
present the report please
thank you mr chairman it's hannah
dungate speaking on behalf of miss
matthews
this is a summary of the officer
presentation made to the last district
planning committee in july
by way of an herbal update to members
before we move on
the rams contribution discussed at
paragraph 4.4.2
and sections 5.8 and 7 of the officers
report
as well as in the heads of terms is out
of date and should be updated to reflect
an
increased fee of 125 pounds 58 per
dwelling
which is due to indexation as part of
the new financial year
this application seeks outline planning
permission on a strategic allocation in
malden
for a mixed response up to 320 dwellings
it also includes the provision of b1
employment land
community uses and a relief road
all matters of detail are reserved for
future determination as part of reserve
matters applications
except for means of access to the site
which is considered as part of this
application
this report is an update to that
considered at planning committee in
march 2017
at which it was resolved to grant
planning permission for the development
subject to a section 106 agreement being
signed and conditions being imposed
as the section 106 agreement has not
been completed
outline planning permission has not
currently been issued
as you can see from this slide it just
shows the
locations of the knowles farm buildings
here
morrison's here and the lindenhome site
which is currently
been built out
this slide shows the location of the
current application site
within the south malden garden suburb as
a whole
the application site also forms part of
the south malden master plan framework
as part of the application submitted an
independent
phasing plan has also been received
suggesting that the site could be
developed
into four phases however a detailed
facing scheme would be submitted
prior to the developer seeking approval
for any of the reserve matters
a number of parameter plans have also
been included within the application
which would form part of the outline
planning commission if granted
these include a land use plan which
shows the residential land
in yellow employment land in blue and
community uses
in purple
this is the accessor movement parameter
plan
a landscape parameter plan
building story heights parameter plan
which shows um
up to two stories in the lighter color
up to two and a half stories in the
medium blue
and up to three stories in the darker
blue
this is a residential density parameter
plan showing
medium to high density notified by the
lighter and the dark blue
this is also an illustrative master plan
included within the application
the lyndon homes roundabout has already
been constructed with one arm
into the application site here are some
photos showing that roundabout in place
there is also another roundabout
proposed adjacent to limehouse farm
at the southern end of the relief road
and at the northern end of the relief
road is a
new junction onto wick hill
here are some additional photos of the
site
and this slide just includes a summary
of the updates that have occurred since
march 2017
um the most poignant obviously being
that the local development plan is now
approved
the mppf has been revised um we now see
graham's contributions for applications
and the south malden relief road would
be constructed by
essex county council highways as opposed
to
the developer
so to summarize then this application
is for 320 dwellings with affordable
housing
which accords with the strategic
allocation in the ldp
for a minimum of 300 units at the site
there is provision for b1 employment
development up to 12
2 000 square meters c2 and d1 community
uses
open space and pedestrian and cycle
links to the south malden garden suburb
and the wider area
there would also be contributions
towards strategic infrastructure
including
education and early years south malden
relief road
as well as the other requirements this
allocation is the final site in the
south malden garden suburb to be granted
planning permission with the other two
sites now approved
partial one of the sites has been
implemented
um it facilitates the delivery of the
south malden relief road and will also
make a strategic contribution to the
council's five-year housing land supply
the application is consistent with the
requirements of the mppf
the local development plan and the
infrastructure delivery plan
as well as the principles of the
strategic master plan framework
as the development proposed accords with
the site allocation in the ldp
it is therefore recommended for approval
subject to a section 106 agreement
being signed and conditions imposed as
set out in the report
thank you very much chairman
okay thank you thank you hannah tara
have any
members indicated that they would like
to speak
um yes chairman counseling ron and
councillor jarvis indicated the wish to
speak
thank you and councillor edwards i know
that thank you
i'll go with councillor nunn first
please
counsellor nun
yes thank you thank you chair he has
just a
bit of a connection issue just a point
of accuracy really chair that a mention
has been made of lime house farm i
believe it's lime brook farm
right correct my apologies if i got the
incorrect sorry
well done thank you hannah um
um councillor jarvis
um thank you chairman yes um i just
wanted to
ask a few questions really of the
officers in as we're debating this
matter
um in their opinion do they feel
um that the relief road will get built
uh
say within the next three years and do
they
feel that there is sufficient money to
build the relief road
and would they be able to
make the conditions more robust to
ensure that this rather key feature
is more guaranteed and if not
do they consider that the lack of a
relief road would cause
reasonable harm with regards to the
development thank you chairman
thank you casa jarvis mr lee
thank you chairman um
the the leaf relief take back him
the relief road is delivered through
funding
from a number of schemes which the
others have already been granted
planning permission
and this is the final money in the pot
for one of a better phrase so
to be honest without granting plan from
this permission for this
i can guarantee the relief won't be
coming forward partly also because
obviously
it physically sits on this piece of land
what's important to remember is that
the previous application the previous
iterations application members saw in
2017
required the same level of financial
contribution as
this application does the difference was
that the applicant was to build the road
but that would have only been if the
appropriate pot of money was still there
that matter hasn't changed it's just
that essex county council will be
building the road um question is about
will it be built
um it's always a difficult question for
officers to ever say anything will be
built because it's outside us as the
council's
um control um and to a certain extent it
becomes a bit of a moot point based on
the other
two questions and um which are
about is it necessary and can conditions
yeah
conditions can be imposed um i
think if i remember correctly if members
i take members attention to
condition eight in the office's report
in relation to a strategic
phasing plan um which is required prior
submission the first
reserve matters application um
which will require that
um only certain levels of element could
be undertaken and that's how we would
ensure that
the capacity isn't exceeded within the
highway network
and certainly i need to move on to your
next question to be able to fully answer
that one which relates to
the harm there is capacity within the
highway network
within as now um there is
always harm from any development and
any scheme that produces a new dwelling
whether it's one
whether it's a hundred or it's a
thousand will have impacts on the
highway
but it's about assessing whether that is
unreasonable level of harm
to what a man on the clapping omnibus
would think what that means is
is that just because you might have to
wait a junction a little bit longer or
there might be more cars on the road
it's not automatically harmful
the highway authority have accepted that
a certain number of
weddings can still be built without
exceeding the capacity that sits within
malden district counts also modern
districts not the council of the
district malden's highway network
um and the phase in condition is would
be tied in with that to ensure that
there wouldn't be any harm
so if the relief road did not come
forward it shouldn't be a problem
because there shouldn't be any
additional housing or community land or
however
we've phased it through the agreement to
ensure that
the harm doesn't exist so there would be
a cap on development
for one of the better phrase that would
ensure that the
capacity within the network wasn't
exceeded hopefully that's answered your
questions
thank you chad thank you mr
lee um did you want to come back on that
counselor jarvis
well i think uh obviously for giving us
that detailed answer i have to say
uh i think from a layman perspective you
know we would look at this and say
there was a deal made at some point
where relief roads seem to be guaranteed
now it seems to be less certain so i can
understand people having some concern
but i think council
thank officer league sorry for giving us
that detailed response thank you thank
you jim
thank you very much the next speed drive
is councillor edwards
uh thank you chairman um this is for
matt lee through the chair i have two
questions
firstly at the last meeting i understood
that some
106 money was to be taken from the north
haveries garden suburb
to finance the nose farm link road on
the basis that the traffic
from the north havens gun suburb would
use the niles farm
link road my question is first of all
what evidence does the applicant have
for that
and i would argue that the reverse is
more likely traffic is much more likely
to go from the null
nars farm link road to haybridge and the
a12 chicory
and colchester than traffic from the
north hebrews garden suburb to
chelmsford
if we're not careful the north haven't
gone suburb will run out of money
to build the north hamish garden suburb
link road
and so babies will not only lose a
possible flood alleviation scheme
but the link
sorry i've clicked a button can you hear
me sorry
yeah now i'll lose the flooded
liberation
game but the link road as well that's my
first question
and my second one is that the developer
has or is making provision for a health
hub
now will the access to the health hub
be on the same road that the access to
the residential area
um be the same one or
will be a separate access to the health
hub because then you'll have patients
coming into the health lab
who actually don't live on on these on
the
residential side thank you
thank you councillor edward so that's
money from the north average suburb to
pay for the south moulder one
and uh the provision for the health hub
access mr lee thank you chairman um
the north heybridge garden suburb query
i think
is something that's maybe has grown and
been taken slightly
out of context what the point is is that
the no in relation to section i said
before and members know
normally a section 106 is tied in very
strictly
for what it can and can't be done um
and that ties very specifically
my understanding is that when it comes
to the contributions for the north hey
bridge garden suburbs
there is some ambiguity for one of a
better phrase or a little bit of wiggle
room
for any monies that is left over rather
than having to be returned to the
developer
to be used on another site because there
is acceptance that
the vehicle movements may cause impact
further what within the district
so it wouldn't there's not an automatic
that this
money is from another site it's going to
be used for this to deliver this if so
i think members need to not to allow
hopefully allay those fears that is not
what has been suggested
um sorry well i thought it was at the
last minute no i think if so
through chairman yeah i think um it was
there was a discussion point around this
because i think essex have said about
there is an
ability to move someone but that what
that is is that if there is
excess left over normally we would have
to return it to developers
um but with this there is a point that
there is
there is a bit of x wording slightly
differently so we can offset other harm
within the district so
if there is monies left over we would be
able to put that towards this for
example we could put it somewhere else
if there's a
accepted issue if there isn't an issue
we'd still have to give it back but
we just were quite aware that the
haybridge garden suburb might cause
some other harm further out so that's
how the council's dealt with that
and um i think that may have been a bit
stumbling blocking it i apologize if i
was one of those problems with that last
time it committed we didn't get across
that point accurately
um because i do think that was something
that members picked up at the time and
were concerned that
so hopefully that hopefully should allow
your fears and any other members
regarding that
in relation to health hub um i can't
really comment that because there is no
health habits part of this application
what there is though is community land
and
that phasing plan is will take into
account the uses of the land that come
off of that
this relief road so it i know we're
talking about the housing because that's
what we've normally talked about and
that's the big issue but that phasing
plan would also
build in uses the community
land as well because they come off that
the commercial lands difference as a
separate access
so yeah okay it's in its entirety we
will look at the various points
and the car movements and ensure that
the impact doesn't
happen as you said it's unlikely that if
there's community land whether it's a
health hub whether it's
um a village hall or whatever you know
it's unlikely that all those residents
will only come from that
from the new housing we totally get that
and the system accepts that and what
it's done is is
designed to allow an overall traffic
assessment so the phasing will
cap it it may be weak and overall it's
not just the housing just also in case
members were worried about that
hopefully there are other layers of
fears in relation to those two points
thank you very much
thank you thank you so can i ask both
members and officers to keep
their questions and responses concise
we've been going two and a half hours
now but
i do want to make sure that this gets a
good airing um tara i've got councillors
bamford swain
shaughnessy and morris to speak next do
you have any others
no chairman that's that's all i've got
thank you thank you councillor bamford
thank you chairman thank you um i just
wanted to
um make members very clear on this which
i think the officers could have
made this more clearer to our members
that
this application was agreed before
so we have agreed the housing it is the
strategic site in the ldp
so it is important that that part of it
is explained because the reason it's
come back
and this is the second time it's come
back is because the section 106
agreement
um required the developer to fund
the road and now it's changed
so the essex county council is now
funding the road so that's the only
change
really to to anything as far as i'm
aware
um and i think we now are totally
reliant on our expert
planners and officers to make sure
that they robustly liaise with essex
county council over this
we get the phrasing plan completely
right
and if there is some demonstrable harm
which is when we can take action and
that it's not from a resident's point of
view it's from a
planning point of view that we take
action
immediately to resolve this because
this road is so important to the
district
and that's why we had major concerns
last time so on the basis that the
officers can assure us that they're
going to do all that
i'm quite happy chairman to propose that
this application
is agreed thank you thank you very much
thank you before we thank you councillor
thompson before we go any further
um as i say we've been going for two and
a half hours now i'm going to propose
uh that we have a short comfort break
um uh do we
think of it ten thank you ten minutes
would be sufficient
five five five five mr chairman five
minutes
okay um uh is that okay with you tara
[Music]
um yes chairman um it's probably best if
you set the time that we're going to
come back out
with the easiest thing all right okay
the time now i've got it as
3 33 uh i suggest we come back at 3
40. agreed
thank you okay thank you okay
yeah so at this stage um do we
um tara do we log off or do we just
pause
members can stay logged on what we'll do
is we'll just pause the um the live
recording so if you just bear with me i
confirm that's been done
okay once we've done that we'll pause
and uh
340 if members could be back as quickly
as they could please thank you
yeah confirm we're back live now
chairman thank you thank you very much
welcome back uh members and members of
the public
and officers um so we've finished with a
point
from um councillor bamford uh i'm now
going to move on to the next speaker
which
is counselor swain your question please
yes thank you chairman um
[Music]
i want to confirm the question of these
accesses
um there is an access from the
commercial area separate from the
residential and from what the office has
showed
um the community area is on the other
side as i understand it of what would be
the
um the relief road um it
showed a roundabout so i don't
not sure whether there is another access
from either the
residential area or the employment area
onto that relief road there whether it's
solely access to the
community area my question then
is if it comes to this question of
delay or over um
building the relief road whether the
temporary access that
has been talked about would in fact be
um the access that is shown
on the uh the diagram of rather complex
um junction or would it be something
simpler
um but the other point is of course if
um
if this is essentially a separate area
um and has an access road onto wick hill
it seems to me that there's no reason
why that cannot be
um started on much sooner
it doesn't have to be the last stage of
the um
the whole development but um could be um
discussed and organized with the county
council
much sooner um
the question of the whole
extent of the relief road and whether it
will be
helping hey bridge one way or the other
this is
all and the link to the a12 this is all
to do with the highway structure
and not really directly connected to
the development at knowles farm
picking up what councilor bamford has
said
um this is a essentially been
agreed and the problems we have are not
with
the dartmouth park estates they're going
to be with essex county council
so i think um you know there's no reason
why we shouldn't
um progress this um planning application
and carry the carry the fight onto uh
essex county council highways all right
thank you
so much thank you so mr lee so i think
we've got three questions there the
roundabout access
the timing of the relief road and the
extent is that correct
well and whether whether the temporary
access quote
um could be actually started so to
open up the community area um
okay i'll move over to mr lee to respond
please
thank you chairman i will i will
actually pass over to the case officer
ms matthews but obviously i would like
to highlight is this is
outline application at this stage so
things such as the community land use
will still need to come in for a reserve
matters application
but i'll pass over to ms matthews okay i
think it's hannah isn't it
um good afternoon chairman catherine
matthews is here
i am here um i wasn't sure about how my
availability this afternoon so i didn't
want to um
be sort of the main officer but i am
here to answer questions
um as a case officer as as as and when
um needed so
in terms of the um the community land
there
as as the councillor has suggested that
there
there would be uh the possibility of
that land having it having
direct access onto wick hill um
separately almost to um
um the relief road um
coming into um coming forward
it i mean the ideas have been have been
um suggested that you know that that
access could form part of the relief
road
um um subsequently but that there are
sort of details that
um as as mr lee suggested um
would come through as part of any
reserve matters or detailed application
for
development of community land and and at
that point
um the progress on on delivering the
relief road would
would be assessed um as part of that
that application
um so there are other options available
and
and um the the response back from the
county council
um the most recent one basically says
that again
if the relief road isn't in place when
when when
access to the community land is needed
then other options will be
can be could be looked at and that is
one option that that could be looked at
at that time
and assessed in the normal way um
i don't think i've got anything else to
say at the moment but if that hasn't
answered
a question any other questions then let
me know and i'll come back again thank
you
anything you want to come back on there
just to question if um
the access were
put in with only the community area in
view
and not continuation of the relief road
the construction of the rest of the
reflow
would the would you foresee the junction
being
similar as if it was for a relief road
or would it
could it be much simpler for mr lee
yes steve chairman i think that's a
matter for outside of this application
this is only the outline and this isn't
for consideration at this time
so um i can't we can't really give you
an answer unfortunately council this way
no it's to take up with the county
council yeah
all right okay thank you very much
councillor
shaunicy
thank you chairman um just very briefly
um
i've got you know notes as other
councillors have about the relief road
but i think a lot has been said about
that this afternoon and i am aware of
time chairman thank you
um but um i would just like to ask are
either miss matthews or
or mr lee um the developer
states that all of the 320 homes
can be accessed off the so-called linden
roundabout
and the um ecc highways has indicated
acceptance of this um page 77
5.10.7 if anyone wants to uh
check that um does either ms matthews or
mr lee agree um that this is
um satisfactory and the emer emergency
vehicles
would have access to all of the
residents
using this road or indeed obviously the
road off
of wick hill i would just like i was i'm
just checking that please uh
three chairman i'm i'm aware that the
applicant has stated obviously
to certainly that goes in conflict off
the cuff i'm
like miss matthews can correct me if i'm
wrong with what the influence we have at
the time
but formally but that also doesn't take
into account the community
land and that's why obviously there is
that condition in relation to phasing
and officers will look at it in its
totality rather than
ensuring that one type of development or
anything is prioritized over the other
but that's the reason for the phasing
condition
is in relation to that but we will have
that definitive at the time
we haven't got that confirmed one way or
the other thank you sharon
oh okay all right thank you thank you
chairman
okay thank you for that concise question
and answer thank you
um councillor morris
thank you folks i would just like to uh
make a short
more of a statement than a question um i
just would like it noted for and on the
record
but um the common sense for this would
be that there's going to be
with the um housing that's been pushed
onto haybridge there's going to be
1600 new dwellings uh what with the bum
fluffery that's going on
at the a12 as well um if
bradwell is uh approved and we have all
that traffic going through
will this application actually become
known as the biggest free car park
morton district council has ever
approved
thank you okay
thank you thank you for that uh tara do
we have any other
people wishing to speak please oh
councillor edwards yeah chairman cancer
stamp and counselor
sorry catherine and councillor edwards
okay councillor stamp first because i
think you haven't spoken yet council
standing
german i'll give way to councillor
edwards because my bit
needs to come at the end so i'll give
way to council redwoods if that's all
right with you chair
well yes it's uh it's a second bite of
the cherry but i will accept this go
here
councillor edwards uh thank you
councillor stamp uh
it's really just to clarify my first
question i asked
that the extra money is coming
to to pay for the uh the road was
indicated that it would come from the
north hebridge garden suburb what i
meant was
although i know that it's as it's kind
of council are doing the road it was the
short fall
i was talking i was actually referring
to and where was that money coming from
thank you just to clarify
thank you very much mr lee the shortfall
on the section 106 money
do you chairman um i think it's
important to obviously know that at the
moment there is no confirmation there is
a shortfall
um i know people have been stating that
i think it's five million i've heard as
the essex county council have confirmed
they haven't done any when any real work
on it
to formally have any exact figure and i
think
the shortfall in the uh ldp potential a
worst case scenario is much smaller than
five million
um and it's a pragmatic figure that the
council took as a likely
cost that should be more than enough to
cover the ring relief road and
you know that's why the inspector
accepted it if the it was thought to be
thought to be a figure quite
substantially
sure um i don't think any inspector
would have accepted that as part of the
ldp
because it would have meant that through
the phasing the housing wouldn't have
come then we wouldn't have had our five
year land supply etc so it would have
fundamentally floored it where does that
funding come from if there is a
shortfall
um that's an interesting question um
there's many options
es6 in theory could look to meet the
shortfall if they
consider there's a benefit there are
different options in relation to looking
at getting funding for
highways on its own if it was stopping
the housing coming through there's ways
of looking to get funding for
infrastructure to deliver
um housing projects that have stalled um
to be honest you know cancer there's
there's more options in theory to look
at it than i can go through in
you know it this afternoon but yeah
there are things out there thank you i
just wanted to clarify that
thank you right councillor stem
i think uh yeah thank you chairman um
did councillor bamford put a proposal on
the table
i think she did and explained quite
clearly that it has been here before
if council banford has put it on the
table to agree the
officer's recommendation um can we
actually move towards that
chairman and can we actually ask mr lee
to put the robust conditions in that he
advocated for and said he would
on the road that's my proposal on my
second into council of bamford if she
proposed the recommendation chair
okay councillor benfitt did you want to
just go over your
proposal
um sorry chairman um yes i did make a
proposal but
i wanted the reassurance from the
officers
that they would ensure the conditions
were robust uh the phasing plan was
robust
and if they can give us those assurances
then i propose that we agree the
recommendation
and i think maddie thompson actually
seconded my proposal
okay yes thank you councillor thompson
so
following consideration of that legal
advice
um given in agenda item seven
and this motion has been put forward
and seconded um i will now put it
to the vote so tara can you sorry
chairman
can we have the re the assurances from
the officers that
um these robust conditions are going to
be
um implemented please before we take the
vote
certainly sorry i thought i thought they
had mr lee could you give those
assurances
three chairman um condition a as
discussed earlier deals with the phasing
plan reserved applications if
members are minded to they can grant
plan permission subject to that
condition being agreed by officers
through consultation with the chair just
to make sure that if there is any
ways or necess necessity to make it any
more robust
um but some of the other points are
actually that is what would be agreed
through that condition in the latter day
so there is no
guarantee of this now through a
condition but what i can assure you is
that officers will
deal with it all professionally and
ensure that we mitigate the harm as
always
thank you chairman
is that are you satisfied with that
counselor banford
so um thank you chair um
so what um the officer was saying is
that a particular condition
could be improved in liaison with
yourself
and i'm happy with that yeah well at
least it looked at being i wouldn't want
to guarantee
say that it can be because i would
consider our conditions generally are
fairly robust and defendable but i'm
happy to
review that one with the champ
consultation
the officer's recommendation is that we
uh we accept that we
approve this recommendation so
uh tara could we have um the vote
alphabetically please
uh yes chairman chairman just also to
point out you made reference to the
legal advice and the gender item
seven it was a gender item five just to
avoid any confusion
i'm sorry no that's fine i just wanted
to make sure it was clear
and so members um just as we've done
before i'm going to call the names
alphabetically if you could indicate if
you're for against or abstaining please
so i'm starting with a councillor
bamford please
well i am for tara provided that
condition is looked at
because that's not part of the
recommendation so chairman is the
recommendation being amended to
therefore include that
that the condition be looked at yes
please
yes please yeah
okay so i'm voting for on that basis
okay well i think that would have to be
the motion won't it
sorry chairman it would need to be the
motion okay
so carry on so councillor bassinger
please
mrs fleming for thank you
uh councillor heard i will abstain
for thank you councillor hull
four thank you councillor jarvis
four thank you lagan
against that's amazed
against you counseling morris
against chancellor nunn
or cancer shaughnessy
that's the schemes abstain thank you
cancer stamp sorry tara at four
thank you very much councillor stilts
against
councillor swain for
you councillor mrs thompson oh
thank you it is 14 4
4 against and two abstentions
thank you thank you very much thank you
and thank you members uh for coming to
that decision
um we'll now move on to agenda item nine
which is the land
east of bradwood power station downhill
beach bravo long sea
this is found on pages 195
to 250 please note that a members update
in relation to this application
has also been circulated prior to the
meeting
and i will now call on the officer to
present this
item which is uh miss hannah please
present the report thank you devon
thank you chairman so this presentation
is to provide a brief summary of the
proposal and to remind members and also
the public
of the content within the presentation
and the office's report that was
presented at the july district planning
committee
and so i'll try and keep it brief
this is a full application which seeks
planning permission
to carry out ground and load test
investigations and associated works
this includes the creation of two site
compound areas and associated parking
areas
the works are temporary in nature and i
hope uh
are to help inform the design and layout
of any new nuclear power station that
may be proposed at the site
and to also build on previous
preliminary
investigations which were approved and
undertaken in accordance with the 2017
commission
uh just to note as it did previously
that the application is not the erection
of a new nuclear power station
here we have the location plan
the site layout plan you can see the
compound areas are highlighted in pinks
this is where the load test
investigation works will take place
and the smaller compound area
so this is the um
sorry this plan shows the access route
so we've got the primary access routes
and within the dotted line and then the
secondary access routes
and so out within the wider part of the
site the site also shows the indicative
site in the ground investigation works
which will be in the form of boreholes
and trial pits
this is the ground investigation
compound layout
and the load test investigation compound
this shows the areas for ex excavation
surrey
and which has been the middle and the
areas where the buns will be
located there's also an attenuation pond
and welfare
facilities which are located to the
south
this plan just shows the earthworks in
greater detail
the proposed sections of the showing the
proposed load test works
and sections showing the height of the
embankments
photos of the surrounding area and the
access to the site
here we have some more photos
within the site and showing um the
control tower
and then some more photos taken from
within the site
so since the meeting in july and further
objecting comments have been received
from essex wildlife trust
which were dated the 12th of august 2020
and we've had some public letters of
ejection
they're not considered to raise any new
material considerations
and likewise the concerns relating to
ecology contamination noise pollution
oh sorry they raised concerns relating
to ecology contamination noise pollution
and the necessity to reconsider the
application
but these are say not considered to
raise material considerations
therefore as previously reported overall
it's not
it's considered that subject to
mitigation measures that have been
proposed
and given that the site will be returned
to its pre-development condition
the development would not have a
detrimental impact on the character and
landscape of the area
the nearby natural heritage designations
archaeological features eco ecological
receptors or the environment as a whole
they're also not considered to be
detrimental impacts on the highway
network
so subject to conditions including those
safeguarding the implementation of
mitigation measures regarding
noise disturbance contamination the
protection of any archaeological remains
and protected species and sites
the development is considered acceptable
and is recommended for approval
thank you chairman thank you devon
uh so uh members have received uh
legal advice legal advice on this um
tara who do we have who wishes to speak
please
chairman i've got councillor bell
councillor schemes
councillor lagan councillor nunn and
councillor bamford
thank you
thank you very much and
so we'll go councillor bell first please
thank you
um mr chairman i'm firstly i'd just like
to go back to
as i mentioned previously the
current or the upcoming judicial review
in relation to size well
c and mrs justice andrews comments
when allowing the um judicial review
it is arguable that there were
deficiencies within the environmental
impact assessment relied upon by the
council in making their planning
decision
now members i feel we're at severe risk
of this
we've had discussion we've talked about
um the response from the statutory
council to natural england and also
other responses from
interested and very very relevant
organizations and bodies
i feel we're in the same position as
science will see here and that if we
agree to this
we lay ourselves wide open to uh
to judicial review secondly
um i want to talk about small children
members
since sed's primary school as we know is
only
i think i believe 100 yards away from
the site of one of these planned ball
holes
young ears are sensitive and these small
children will be subjected to noise
levels of 78 decibels
now i can circulate information from the
world health organization
members which states that the potential
effects of this
could include hearing loss both
temporary and permanent
impaired cognitive function and
increased stress levels
and alongside that the capacity to learn
well there's that degree of noise going
on is
now members i'm a social worker
in my world this is demonstrable
significant
harm it may not be in planning terms but
it certainly is in my world
and we would also lay ourselves open to
um
parents bringing legal action against
the council for any damage that their
children may have um may have had to
their hearing
just finally briefly um
the government nominated site boundary
is 298 hectares and this application
covers 460 hectares
it therefore actually contravenes
government national planning policy and
falls outside the planning system
and that hasn't been raised by anyone up
until this point
that's it from me thank you mr chairman
you very much indeed um
next on the list i've got um counsellor
schemes could i just ask councillor
swain could you switch your camera off
please
thank you councillor schemes oh yes
um time we haven't really had enough
time this has come upon us
uh so quickly we have a selection of
environmental reports uh some of which
contradict each other
we need more robust uh reports into the
impact of this and now i don't know how
we get time
uh i i understand that it's a position
of some officers that
we've got what we've got we've got to go
with what we've got i
i feel we need better investigations
into the environmental
impact in this i'm not sure how we
achieve that
but i don't like being over a barrel of
time for something that isn't going to
be built for
for so long it seems unfair and i you
know i find it very difficult to find a
way to vote in favor of such a massive
uh intervention in our in our
uh environment and i think we somehow or
other we need more time or we need to
face the possibility of appeal which is
possible
and make sure we are thoroughly prepared
thank you
thank you um councillor councillor
lagan do you have a question
i have a question and some points chair
please okay
and i'd like to exercise my right to
speak uh within the three minutes which
i'll try and keep two chairs
okay thank you that was also perplexed
chair while this is on the agenda when
members have already rejected it um this
application members is
is uh states in the proposal that the
application to carry out ground
investigations
and associated works in conjunction with
a new nuclear power station at breville
et cetera et cetera i'll edit it for
time um therefore it's critical critical
for us
in understanding that this application
is intrinsically linked to the proposed
new power station although it is an
application in its own right here
and power station where to note that the
generic design assessment so
the actual assessment of the reactors
and the suitability hasn't
even been passed and approved by the
office of nuclear regulation
so we wouldn't be classed unreasonable
members if we refuse this application
because
at the moment we're considering building
a swimming pool for the loch ness
monster which we don't even know if
exists and we don't even know the signs
of it
so um then we look at the
recommendations within within the paper
that the officers have kindly put
together
um and i i look at proposal number one
is
we even talk about approving the
application well the application itself
is against the the local and national
policies which is obviously planning is
led by the nppf the national planning
policy framework
which provides background against the
application for planning permissions
the the ldp our own modern district
council ldp states in 20 words on page
page 57 that it supports in principle
uh new nuclear power station and
bradwell well yes important principle
doesn't mean that it actually exists
we've already ascertained that we don't
we don't support the principle or the
application
so in essence if if we carry on with
this given that this recommendation to
proceed
goes against the ldp the nppf sections
170
which is conserving and enhancing the
natural environment i quote chair and
members
planning policies and decisions should
contribute to and enhance the nature of
local environment
by point a protecting the enhancement
enhancing
valued landscapes sites of biodiversity
or geological value in soils in a manner
consumer
with their statutory status or
identified quality in the development
plan
nothing there any other principle b
recognizing the intrinsic character and
beauty of the countryside
and the wider benefits from natural
capital and ecosystem
ecosystem services including economic
and other benefits
for more versatile agricultural land c
maintaining this is important
maintaining the character of undeveloped
coast while improving public access
so this is all what the policy says and
and preventing
a a new and existing development from
contributing to or being put at
unacceptable risk or being
adversely affected by levels of soil air
water or noise pollution
etc etc so i believe the first
recommendation that was put in there
goes against section 170 the mppf and
therefore it can't be deemed as
unreasonable which would be a case if we
went to appeal that we have to argue
whether that was unreasonable in regards
to case law um
which would be we've talked about in
previous occasions
um which which really from a procedural
perspective we've not broken any
procedures because
we've followed our procedure so
recommendations two and three
and i take all members would have would
have had the recommendations in front of
them
uh talks to the studies and reports that
don't supply enough detail which which
other members have said
uh with regard to environmental heritage
harm that could occur
and it could occur well it's going to
occur even the advice of the rspb
was ignored the number of boreholes for
instance we've mentioned boreholes
and i've been
this is a very very important thing you
can have my three minutes
you can have my three minutes too i
don't i don't need all of that i just
want to get these points because these
are these are important these are points
as well
so the number of boreholes exceeds 230
which is more than twice the number of
the ninth the 2017 application
this will a borehole will cause harm for
both ecology heritage damage and noise
pollution
so there are material considerations in
planning laws i've been
widely uh led to understand we have to
consider those
also members a temporary 200 meters by
100 meter open cut excavation with
further four meter and seven meter
excavations at the bottom of the pit
can't be classed as minor excavations
and that will create harm
and it's a material consideration noise
disturbance dust disturbance
and we allow that to sit in place for
three years um i think
that the temporary for calling that
temporaries is naive
recommendation number five is actually
contradictory it allows the compounds
uh the grounds to be leveled if after
five years permission
is not granted for a new power station
as he recommended before
but it says the testing has to cease
after three years
so we just leave the compound there do
we if we haven't done anything so that's
again that's harm because it certainly
doesn't fit in
with the beautiful peninsula at bradwell
tech recommendation 7
talks about temporary structures in the
site compound not exceeding 10 meters
think about how high 10 meters is that's
30 foot um
and what that does it says to me our
policies d1 and h4
policy d1 states all developments must
must respect and enhance the character
and local context
and make a positive contribution and b
it doesn't
and h4 where it states the proposal will
not involve the loss of
important landscape heritage features
for ecology
interests the proposal does therefore uh
contradict itself against our own
policies nearly done chair thank you
recommendation number nine it talks
about the times of development
so it says the development should not
commence between seven and twenty
hundred hours monday to fridays that's a
long hard working day
um that's again outside our own policies
the noise levels and disturbance
work resulting from such hours of
operation are going to be harmful unlike
concur with council and bell that
doesn't include chair members
mobilization and disturbance caused by
people getting down there and also the
negativity on ecology
recommendation 12 and 13 drilling and
aquifer
protection in this clause also takes
the further contaminated land is
identified the time scales for the
cessation and redeem your works
should take place that could take years
right
you over double the amount of time here
recommendation 16 development according
to mitigation
included in the landscape in the visual
report to predict the character and
appearance of the landscape in
accordance with their own policies
chair members sa d1 s8 states the
countryside will be protected for its
landscape
natural resources and ecological value
well and its intrinsic character and
beauty
ball holes and open cut excavations go
against that and section 170 the mpf
section 17 by its own part again says
the ecology
is there doesn't even enter into that
and recommendation
19 talks about noise pollution and
mitigation noise pollution is a material
consideration
that's going to be in excess of what the
recommended exposed lanes
i would like to go
this is so important i've i've been
generous i've been given
seven minutes and and the constitution
please
i will go to councillor bamford then
please
i recommend refusal that's my only last
mata chair and thank you for cutting me
short
when we obviously have this massive
decision to make i find that very very
very helpful
i think i've been very generous
counselor with seven minutes
thank you councillor there's a
recommendation on the table
council of banford
uh chair i think councillor nunn was
trying to speak
in is muted okay councillor none
can we can i go back to you
thank you and meet yourself
counselor none of your music counselor
man
can you hear me now yes thank you um so
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor lagan for your eloquent
presentation
um i want to concentrate uh entirely on
the groundworks here chair
the application before us uh not comment
on the power station per se
uh i'll reserve those thoughts uh for
later
i want to talk about the impact on the
built heritage
and i've been reminded on a number of
occasions uh that i must
base my comments on evidence so here you
are then
i'm basing the evidence on brb's own
materials
their own materials uh in terms of guilt
heritage
talk about keeping the memorial
uh as important as the memorial is it
only dates
from the 12th of july 1987. however
the uh brb paper is worryingly silent
on the actual real remains of the
aerodrome
they make no mention of the control
tower or watch office
they make no mention of the station
headquarters no mention of the
uh belmont and blister hangers and no
mention of the runway remains
and the perimeter track all of those
date from 1941
they are all unique to our district
they're all of national importance in
the context of world war
ii night fighter operations
um and uh we we're told that these
items well we've got no comment from brb
about these items although
officers are saying to me there's no um
indication that these will be removed
but
my goodness with the amount of work
that's planned there
there will be at the very least damage
and there will be at the very least
visual disruption
uh because these things will be hidden
behind earthworks
i've also heard that anything can be
returned and replaced
and rebuilt um that surely is impossible
i'm not convinced by that
we're talking about reinforced concrete
with some of this
some of these structures so there's this
is nothing short
in my mind chairman of heritage
vandalism
and wouldn't it be tragic uh if um after
all of this
um this vandalism takes place but then
the power station itself doesn't go
ahead
and yet where we end up with irreparable
damage
done to the legacy of a very important
historic site
thank you very much all right thank you
very much indeed for that
council of nun council of banford
thank you chair this has been a long
afternoon
and this is a very important planning
application
and for the benefit of any residents
that are
listening i just want to explain
how difficult this is for us as
councillors
in making this decision we know the
government have
allocated the site for a new power plant
we know that in the past this council
has supported nuclear
um and we have
our offices recommending approval
so we're relying reliant on our expert
planners and officers to advise us
on these things um we have statutory
council teas that are all
in favor of this application that's
archaeological
ecological heritage assets they're all
in favor our conservation officer hasn't
raised
any objections and um
although there's a raft of public
opinion against
this we've been told that this is not
um per se a reason
to object so we are really
as a council between a rock and a hard
place here
because unless we can come up with some
expert that was our legal advice we have
to have
substantial um expert advice that would
support
objections to this planning application
and we don't have those
so we are really in a problem here with
this application i've heard what
well i heard what uh councillor lagan
has said
and he has put forward an objection but
we need to know exactly
the reasons um because it was a long
long speech
and it has been seconded but i i'm sure
that i
and other members have no idea what
those
objections are so we need to know if
there's a proposal on the table
so i'm very very reluctant to propose
anything here
although you know we have got our
offices
who are our experts recommending
approval
so that's what i want to say chairman
and i would like
a detailed um clear
explanation from councillor lagan as to
exactly what he is putting forward
as the points for refusal
thank you all right thank you i will i
will come back to that
uh but i i want to hear from people who
haven't spoken yet
councillor shaughnessy
councillor shaughnessy
ah there we are thank you chairman um
yes um i agree um with um
councillor bell about the school um and
as a retired teacher
i would not want to teach in those um
that sort of situation um i agree with
everything she said there
um i'd also like to mention the care
home um
the the i believe it's called the down
hall care home
um the devastating effect it will have
on
the residents there and of course
all the residents of bradwell you know
it goes without saying um the
um 460 hectares that
now has been mentioned i mean do these
extra hectares
fall outside the planning system um i'd
like to know that the same as um
councillor bell i don't know why the
rspca
cannot be um consulted again
um and while we're on consultation um
all the
parish councils it is years since that
consultation
um was held but it still comes up in the
agenda
uh why ca why can that uh
not be revisited uh and all the parish
councils
um be um ask their opinion now
um and just um two specifics um
council and none um mentioned the um
effects of the um
historic uh and architectural artifacts
that are there
being disturbed by all this drilling etc
there are some protected species in the
area
as well as all the other species that
are there
um that will be affected by all this
drilling
um the the noise um and um
and as i said in closed session um
with reference to these in particular
protected species
but all species particularly the ground
and water species
um that sound travels fastest
through soil then it gets to the water
and it's a little slower then it gets to
the air and it's a little slower still
so there is no protection for these
species
at all with this drilling um thank you
chair
thank you very much so i know we've had
a proposal a second year but i don't
want to stifle debate i do apologize i
missed out councillor morris
i know you wanted to make a point
councillor morris
thank you chair um i would just like to
come back
i think councillor benford was saying
about we
must listen to our officers i think more
importantly we need to listen to our
residents
i believe from the correspondence i've
received that our residents demand
that we fight this proposal um i
personally won't be blackmailed bribed
or bullied
into um not representing my residence
i'd asked councillor bamford how she
would feel if she would feel the same
way
if this monstrosity was going up in
tullesbury
i'm also quite disappointed that
councillor langan
was closed down i believe he has some
very
very good points that need to be
listened to
and i would propose that he is given
enough time to adequately put
his uh points across um i believe i've
got support in the chamber and i believe
that the uh that councillor langan
should
be referred back to to finish his
original
um points thank you very much
thank you councillor helm um i have you
got your camera on to speak
yes please okay i'll i will put you on
the list
uh and i will also put councillor swain
i just need to hear people who haven't
spoken before
councillor jarvis
councillor jarvis yep yeah thank you
chairman um
yes i just wanted to say i mean i have
i've read all the documents
and uh i think it's in uh it's important
to take on board
uh of course from a human nature point
of view we're taking on board what the
residents are saying
but from a planning point of view we
have to understand that
um you know that that that is what we're
being asked to determine on
uh on planning um that said
i have to say i'm i'm very disappointed
that we don't seem to have got
i've made much inquiry ourselves at all
into any expert
reports we're relying entirely on it
seems
reports which have been produced um
statutory reports
on firms organizations recommended by
the government i mean there are lots of
other organizations
regarding uh you know ecology landscape
heritage
uh ecology there are lots of other
organizations that i'm sure
um for not exorbitant costs at all would
be able to produce
robust and detailed statements and if
they can't
um and they're not able to do that then
i think councillors are
faced with a more sort of balanced
decision but it seems to me at the
moment that we haven't really
that hasn't really been pursued at all
and so what we're being presented
with is to make a decision which is
based on
skewed information to that degree that's
not the officer's
fault but i do think um
you know having a longer period of time
to get those
appropriate reports is very important
because you know this is something which
is
very large and something which is going
to be around for a very long time
and it's going to affect an awful lot of
people um so i really
find it quite puzzling and somewhat
bizarre that uh
you know we can't put the time in um to
at least
attempt to get expert reports and you
know if they're not forthcoming or they
come up with the wrong conclusions at
least councillors then
and residents would be able to see a
balanced view
but at the moment i feel you know very
much very strongly that we're
we're being given uh a few reports and
we're being told
that's it make your decision based on
these and i feel very uncomfortable
about that thank you chairman i just
wanted to make that point
thank you very much councilmember
thank you chairman just get in mind
before just before we start
cancer siddha councillor morris has
raised a point of order what point of
order would that be please councillor
morris
i believe we've um not followed
procedure by asking the world member for
their
um opinions first can we not get the
world member for bradwell's opinion
uh for this please um i don't think he's
present at this meeting
oh so sorry that the councillor that is
in charge of
that wald uh councillor duik isn't
actually in the meeting
there you go thank you okay
councillor can i go back to councillor
please
thank you chairman uh
yeah i i think that
yeah that all the points that uh people
have made so far
are extremely valid and
under the noise alone and the effect
that that would have on the community
it's above the limits that that's
declared so
that alone surely should be a reason for
refusal
there must be consultants that we can
talk about that
so i i am unaware of
what the time scales are in terms of
this application and how soon
it's got to be approved so perhaps we
could have a look at a proposal
that we uh delay making a decision on
this
until that expert advice can be sought
and whether
that is something that we can do that we
don't make the decision
um and that it can be it can be today
for a bit longer until we get more
expert advice
that we can make a a qualified decision
on
um i would have just to ask
thank you for that i'll ask mr quelch um
is this a is this a matter that can be
deferred or should we
do we have to decide today please you
can you can defer a planning application
of course you can
um if you want more information the
problem is that my understanding is that
this application
has already had an extension agreed by
the applicant i believe
it it may well be the end of august
or the beginning of september um simon
it is today i mean today
so um yeah okay so thank you for that so
the situation is legally
legally members should make their
decision today
if if members don't
then the applicant can
make an appeal to the planning
inspectorate for non-determination
that that's a matter for them they may
accept the reasons for the council that
the council want to get more information
i think members would need to actually
define what that information
is specifically they want so officers go
away and get exactly what's required
so the answer is it needs to be decided
today legally
and it would depend on the applicant's
response to
um to that about an appeal
all right thank you very much was that
your only other point council
uh yes it was thank you chairman thank
you very much councillor helm
counselor howard please be brief as well
if you've made it thank you
councillor
you're still muted i think
come on now thank you mr k yes yes i can
hear you
sorry about the delay um
highways have said the road network's
all right but i maintain it isn't
uh lakshmanan will be gridlocked and the
pollution levels
will be way above the recommended levels
going further along
through steeple we've got great listed
buildings there
that are being destroyed now let alone
in future
uh talking about the noise level
a typical lawn mower is 100 db
so that could be working next to the
school and 78 decibels will be quite
quiet
and now i would like to refer you to the
wind farm that was passed by the
expectorate
even though the people of the district
didn't want it
so it's obvious what's going to happen
in the end it's going to be
forced through by somebody else and we
won't have enough say in it
and that's all i have to say i won't
need the 12 minutes
of federal remember that's it thank you
mr chairman
thank you very much and i'm going to go
now to
to counselor swain i think he's uh yeah
you're
please if you could be brief please
counselor slain i'm not sure
that i can't be succinct it would be
ironic if actually the ground
investigation showed the place was
unsuitable but
um a couple of things i want to clarify
um this is a 2.2 meter fence
all around the site as i understand it
um
is it an effective sound barrier can it
be ensured it's an effective sound
barrier
um the reason for the sight area
i mean there may be various reasons for
that one is that for practical purposes
at this stage but in the longer round
the actual area
um encircling the plant
maybe smaller um
the other thing is where the
recommendations we have if they're
passed
i assume they would become conditions
that's wrong for mr lee um i think
council's opinion is understandable
because the reasons we
gave or we um the mr
lee gave were rather weak and also the
the documentation is sprayed around with
saying provided mitigation measures are
included
um which is a bit of a a catch-out
catch-all um
now um i don't accept some of these
arguments about
the 2025 deadline and the boundary
definition i don't think they
really matter i think we've got two
possible approaches
one is to refuse it because of lack of
information
and the other is to impose additional
conditions
or tighter conditions on the first
one could list a few things where we
could
want further information such as
radiological contamination
the impact of vibration on wildlife and
people
not just noise um a bit more
certainty about dealing with drilling
fluids
and the justification for so many
boreholes and
this very large pit that's one approach
which um mr lee may think still
is too weak the alternative is to look
at the recommendations
and other possible recommendations or
conditions
one would be to reduce the years the
number of
the period in recommendation three from
five years to three
to change the working hours in
recommendation nine for
from eight to five and i can't see any
reason for
any noisy late working condition
10 we could require 55 decibels at all
times as a maximum
to the outside world and we could put in
additional conditions that there must be
no damage to heritage assets
and the second one um perhaps we could
reduce the size of the pit it seems to
me very
large for the um
the uh object of the exercise
um and one might question also the
numbers of
boreholes but whether we can actually
as we say put in a condition of a
limited number
with them to come back from what they
needed them no bigger pit
if they needed it maybe an option
the last point is um on page 219
5.6.9 um
this pencil is working in evenings i
can't see
that that we should have any noise noisy
um
operations um in the evening
um the last thing is with the timing of
this they were due to start in june july
and finish in november i wonder if
because of
um environmental ecological concerns
they have to move all of this activity
into next year
all right thank you um uh before i ask
for any other speakers
is there anything you need to come back
on uh mr lee at all
i know you've had a lot of information
there thank you i think uh
ms hernan probably would come back on a
lot of it at first as the case officer
is quite um specific to that and then
i'll um
come in on any points that either i
think might need
additionality or outside the planning
application all right i'll get it so
i'll get some more views
yeah okay um tara
could i have the next speaker please uh
the next person i've got is councillor
stamped chairman thank you
thank you councillor stamp thank you
chairman um mine is really just a
clarification
by you not allowing council langham to
finish and i appreciate he went
above his time and thank you for doing
that but he
he's following the rest of his speech
may have contained a valid reason for
refusal
now if it did and you didn't allow it to
be debated
that couldn't be noted on to the if this
application was refused chairman
so i just would like to say a word of
caution i understand he's spoken longer
than he should do but
he's very very um informed on this
and i think it's really important that
he is allowed to speak
and he can have my three minutes
chairman thank you
well thank you for that i think he's uh
he actually spoke for over seven minutes
and i think i was very generous on that
can i just go back councillor lagan is
there much more to come
not not much more chair first of all
thank you councillor stamp for your
generosity and other members in your
generosity of listening um no there's
just a couple of points because i was
getting to the
the actual point that what i was going
to mention chair
which it was everything that i spoke to
was was about the recommendations it
wasn't about the nuclear power station
itself
so it's actually about the report so
there's some confusion there but i
might the proposal that i put chair that
we refuse
based on the current gra the current two
reasons for refusal which are just
synoptically with noise and disturbance
ecological matters
and loss of historical environment and
based on the legal advice that we took
earlier on
let's actually seek and appoint
technical experts in these areas
and actually make sure that we have got
every single basis covered
and not be scared to do so that was all
i was going to say chair
that's my reference days thank you very
much
so just to just uh before i um go to the
vote because i think
um first of all mr lee uh we would need
to
um either vote on the office
on the office's recommendation uh and
then
if not go on to councillor legends
uh recommendation is that correct
chairman you can't because you didn't
move the motion first you've already got
a motion on the table
you have to take the motion just ask i'm
just asking mr lee sorry
future i'm not hampton show it's not my
skill set
yeah i think mr crouch might be a better
answer in that one
thank you mr crouch
thank you mr crouch
i'm sorry chairman um a bit slow i'm
muting myself
chairman the the first motion that has
been
seconded on the table is what you must
deal with first of all
and that can be amended uh
but it must be disposed of first of all
so
the debate now is on the motion that's
been put forward that has been seconded
now has there been a motion that has
been seconded
yeah i believe that's councillor lagan's
motion that we refused this and that was
seconded
right in which case then there is that's
the motion on the table
and you must deal with the the the
members must deal with that
motion first of all right okay thank you
very much
before you before you come back council
swain i just need to go to
mr lee uh because did you want to finish
on something mr lee before we take the
vote
yeah i think i said um let case officer
ms herner go through the points and i'll
add any
supplementary or support required lately
okay devin so if i could just ask you to
uh raise any points that you may have
noted there
thank you chairman and so i'll try and
keep the points brief because i think we
did
address a lot of them last time and just
in relation to the fact um i think
council lagos went through a lot of the
ldp policies
so the starting point for decision
making is the council's adopted local
plan and
as as we've got an adopted one and that
is some material weight in determining
the application obviously we do consider
the mppf as well but the ldp is our
starting point
um in with applications like this
there's always going to be
elements of the proposal that don't
necessarily
um it did every aspect of the local plan
but it is a balancing exercise and given
that the works are temporary
and a lot of the hard mention can be
mitigated through the proposed
conditions
um as officers we don't consider that
development is
holy country to the local plan and in
relation to
noise in particular and the school and
care home have been raised by a number
of members
there are actual residential properties
that are located closer to the works
than
in both the school and the care home and
given that the noise assessment
hasn't found that the development would
be
the one should be harmful to those
residents it isn't considered that it'd
be reasonable to reach a different
approach
in relation to the school and care home
and just also to note that
the conditions proposed in relation to
noise are similar to what we as a
council approved under the 2017
permission
and and there's not anything really
before us that would suggest that we
should
adopt a different approach to what we
did when granting that plan in
permission
there was a lot of matters raised in
relation to contamination
dust ecology which i think
the conditions that we've proposed would
be sufficient to mitigate
in terms of ecology specifically though
the works are terrestrial
um and i've been made aware of guidance
from our ecological
consultant that highlights that if works
are terrestrial
then it's unlikely to have an impact on
particular protected marine species
and also there has been back and forth
with natural england and the applicant
requested extra information so it's not
that they've just accepted the
reports from the applicant um straight
off they have worked with them
to ensure that the development will um
any harm will be mitigated as part of
the development
hours of operation we don't have any
specific local plan policies
in place um for hours of operation
again consulting environmental health uh
and other relevant
council teams the and the fact that not
all the works will be taking place at
one time
um it's not considered that
again there wouldn't be any harm
resulting as such from
any work taking place in unsociable
hours and then
i think the one of the last points i
picked up on was
heritage um as i've previously raised
the harm to heritage assets is
considered to be visual and not physical
and so it would be wholly reversible
once the
um works are removed which is secured
via a condition
um i think oh and just to sorry clarify
on one of councillor swain's points
the 2.2 meter higher fencing is proposed
around the compound areas and it's just
security fencing
that wouldn't be around the whole site
there's noise barriers
proposed around the um boreholes which
will only be in place where
each borehole being worked on but
they're not as excessive
to the extent as it's not that
our 2.2 meter high fence would be around
the entire 460 hexa site
and um drilling fluids from the
boreholes as well
would be taken away from the land and
wouldn't be discharged into any nearby
water courses
uh which i think was another point
raised
i think that covers most the point
unless that has anything to add or
any other members thank you there was a
lot there
okay thank you very much um
mr lee did you want to finish up on that
amen um i think
the turn has covered most of them um
one thing i'd like to see in relation to
councillor swain's points about
some alterations to conditions and
things
you know the application is what it is
and um to say things like reducing the
number of
boreholes they can do all the depth or
anything like that wouldn't be
appropriate
um you know the application is before us
at this time
um i just you know some of the council
of latin's points where he was
highlighting things that are material
situation
you know none of the things he
highlighted i've been honest i would say
aren't material consideration
but just because they are material
consideration doesn't mean automatically
that's a reason for refusal there's
still need to be able to demonstrate
harm
um but i think otherwise mrna covered
all the points excellently thank you
very much
thank you very much right um okay i
intend to
take this to a vote in that case
um miss bird are you ready to
uh to take a vote on the recommendation
which
could you just remind us of the
recommendation uh yeah
i would just wonder if council i can
read out again i've got most of it but
not all of it i just want to be clear
exactly on what you're saying please
absolutely um refusal on the ground
noise
and disturbance on ecology matters
basically the first two that we had on
the previous application
the historical environment relating to
archaeology and heritage assets
and this council approves the
appointment or the met the officers to
seek the
appointment of technical experts to
assist us in refusal of this application
based on harm thank you very much
is there any anything else is there any
other reasons for refusal chairman i
think other i think other members had
other reasons didn't they as well
chairman okay are any other any other
members who wish to contribute
to uh this this
uh recommendation
i don't know i don't see i don't know if
risk of judicial review
uh is a reason it probably isn't but um
i still think the differing size is it
is a material consideration the fact
that it may
actually fall outside current planning
law i mean like that the
current planning system i think that's a
really relevant issue
mr chairman thank you
so much
it's important to understand that you
know this application
is for works it's not for the new
nuclear power station it's just
grounding
investigation works which you know the
ground around
the nuclear power station will still
need to be assessed that it can take
impact and it's important to understand
that the mps does
not explicitly state it will only be
this size no more
so i think personally and professionally
i might advise me not to look at that as
well as refusal because
there is nothing within this application
is explicitly saying
that this nuclear power station will be
based a b or c
that is looking at something i don't
think is a consideration for this
application
thank you thank you councillor maize
you've got a final point
uh yeah i was going to actually come
back on that one about it's about the
size of the site the application
um that is on the table irrespective of
um the power station is 460 hectares
and that is outside the national policy
which is 298
so i'm i am confused i was confused when
i asked the question initially
um councillor bell has brought this one
up as well
um why are we going against national
policy
um on this application not any other
application on this application
thank you this application is for
groundworks this application isn't for
new nuclear power station
they could if they owned more land they
could average the area red larger
there is nothing that says that any
restrictions that will be put through
other legislation
are going to be impacted on this this is
just a plan application they are looking
at
um area around it you know they're
looking at site
quality as i said you know just
understand you know if
land to the side or somewhere else would
be
problematic they would need to
understand this if this would be impact
on from the construction new power
stations this is a
one of a better appraiser of information
finding exercise so
looking at it to say that an agreement
for size here
is flawed by this application being
larger which is separate says
legislation process is not something we
can defend appeal in my professional
opinion it would be a very dangerous way
to look at it
all right thank you i'm just going to go
back to to councillor lagan as it is his
recommendation
council lagging just very very shortly
chair
and members um again and i appreciate
exactly what mr lee says because i do
have an incredibly high regard for our
planning officers
um but the the no long committee with
property and planning it says
playing officers are there to advise the
recommendation that i've put forward is
look we've got the recommendation that's
there you've given us some great advice
we don't want we don't we don't feel
that that is that advice is is enough
you know so let's look at the real
technical experts that are out there
and if we go to appeal et cetera et
cetera that's it but the motions on the
table to go out there
look at what reasons we can actually got
it and then look at the extra technical
device that's there i think councillor
jarvis actually said that probably not
in such a long
way that i did earlier on okay
all right uh in that case i'm going to
i'm going to move to the vote now um
so tara could you take um
the vote please uh yes chairman so this
is a vote on refusal
uh in accordance with the reasons as
detailed by councillor lagan
yes members um if when i call your name
if you could just
indicate if you're for against or
abstaining please
chairman can it be put on the screen can
it be put on the screen
yes please could we uh could we share
that please tara thank you yeah
if you can give me a minute
um i do apologize members for the length
of time this
meeting has taken place but but we we
have covered two very very important
issues um and uh i've where i can
um i've tried to give as much time as we
can but bearing in mind we've had legal
advice
uh that's um that's probably a
a call so here we have the reason for
refusal that's
roughly what i've written down from what
council lagging said so please
if it's incorrect counseling i can
please advise
chairman can i ask councillor nagan to
look at that little bit i've put in the
in the chat bar to see if he agrees with
that or
does he think it's covered in his his
reason for refusal chairman
can you remind us what it is council
stamp please just it's similar to what
the officers
it does have a detrimental impact impact
on character and landscape and the
environment
yeah i agree councillor um stamp that
that should go in i think it's an
excellent point
thank you
are we able to insert that and tara
yes of course gentlemen where would you
like me to insert that
well i think after the word assets i
think probably
heritage assets yeah yeah
the application has a detrimental impact
you know what sorry on character and
landscape and environment
for clarity for officers i'm slightly
confused
are members basically
reiterating their reasons refusal that
were drafted and included within the
office report are they proposing
different reasons for refusal because at
the moment
i think that what's in front of me is
slightly confusing
i would through the chair i would say
that we we need to
look more detailed at those reasons that
we've actually got for the the two
previous reasons
um and also adding the last two parts so
i think we need to
extrapolate much more detail into
exactly why
we feel special about noise so are we
able to
okay are we able to break those down
into separate uh reasons
is that what you're saying today yeah
through your chairman yet because at the
moment it says proposal views based on
the current two reasons views or noise
but
obviously this is the determination the
plan application so the reasons refusal
need to be
laid down clear and precise and
remembering that we need to get that
decision notes out today as well members
so
okay so at the moment it's saying two
reasons and we're putting more of those
taking into account cancer or the
wording of that i would say the two
reasons refusal which we have would be
the starting
block so could those not be put up yeah
i'm just trying to find them
okay
sorry german chairman while this is
going on can i
um raise the point of clarification
please um as i see it we cannot refuse
um and also ask for technical advice we
either have the technical advice
and refuse on that technical advice or
we don't
we can't refuse if we haven't got the
technical advice
is that correct um this is great
or matt lee yeah so through chairman i'm
happy to pick that up
um councillor bamford is correcting that
my assumption was that what council
again was saying that
was the appeal um officers would look to
get additional resources
in to defend the appeals which is what
we would always do anyway um
to defend the council's position but if
i'm wrong
can't um if council wants to clarify i'm
happy for that but yeah
if that is right so it's not uh it's not
something that should go in as a reason
for a refusal this is more
um backing up the reason for refusal is
that correct
german it's not a reason for refusal
that we would have we would do that if
it was refused we would always look to
get
experts to get them okay we just have a
look at the
reviews of the game then please uh so we
can't really refuse
on uh seeking and appointing technical
experts that is what we would do if we
were to refuse it
correct yeah so would it end uh would it
end on the word environment
dude i think what you need to look at is
the two reasons refusal
below that as the basis for starts
obviously we need to have what the
wording is
obviously the text that's above is just
more of a yeah references this is the
reason for you so obviously so i think
we need to have clarity on those points
thank you
thank you so we've got the noise and uh
the ecology matters
are members happy with uh one and two as
they are
with noise could we include vibration
because we're talking about
noise but actually it's the vibration
element that can is
going to be very very very damaging
we need protected species on there as
well
thank you very much under item one there
um it says about namely as a result of
the proximity of the works to the
blister hangers
um i'm not i i did mention not just the
blister hangers but
the watch office their station
headquarters uh the
the perimeter tracks and why are we
saying non-designated
us down the road you know that we just
need to say
name is a result of the works to the
world war two
uh remains uh and the importance in the
heritage context
here absolutely
thank you for that mr quelch did you
want to speak
yes thank you chairman i was just
thinking that obviously members
um this motion is to refuse the
the application the the more reasons
that members put in the more
expert evidence we have to get so for
example noise
is a is a new one members can obviously
add that reason if they want to
but it wasn't a part of the first one
first reason for its views or
so if we if say for example noise is
added
then we would need to not only get
ecology
um archaeological archaeological experts
conservation experts would also have to
get noise experts
so the more the more the more complex
the reasons for refusal
the more experts the council will have
to instruct
now if those are fundamental reasons all
those matters are if members feel those
are all fundamental reasons or the
proposal counselor lagging is the
proposal
counselor lagan feels those are all
fundamental reasons then so be it
i'm just simply making the point it may
be best for councillor lagging to choose
the ones he thinks are the most
objectionable
leave them as they are okay thank you
council councillor none finally
um if we need to get experts so be it um
and actually i don't think we need
archaeological experts
for the reasons i stated earlier what we
need as as an expert
in relation to airfield heritage and
there are some around
okay so um can we move to a vote then
with
one and two
right okay tara could you take the uh
yes is that is so is that being amended
then
it needs an ending a bit about blister
hang as a non-designated
we don't we don't want non-desi we need
to read
you need to take that out and say that
it because of the world war two
um remain and their important their
importance in relation to the local
heritage here here
here here we don't want just kangaskhan
are we able to change that tara
um yes chairman we can change that or we
as members agreed last time
they um the reasons were relating to
noise disturbance on ecology matters
etc and then the exact wording was
delegated to officers in consultation
with the chairman
um members are very clear on what they
wish to say so i think it was probably
best we'd do that
now taking into account that the
decision makers need to go out today
yes please okay also chairman i think
you were going to add vibration
as well
okay if we can just have the
recommendations uh
out please and we'll go from there
chairman if if you advise how you want
it amended i can amend it on the screen
for you
right so on the on the first one
um
so i can't quite see it uh uh
can that be a little bit bigger that's
it thank you
um so counselor none so is there
anything you want to change
in number one yes um
so as a result of the proximity of the
world war two uh aerodrome remains
yeah and we can put them in brackets if
you want
um open brackets tara oh well
what you don't need to go in the detail
really well uh well we could do but i
mean aerodrome
you absolutely do okay all right um
in brackets uh watch office
stroke control tower
comma station headquarters building
uh comma hangers
karma runway remains
perfect
and perimeter track
and then get uh sorry sorry and then get
rid of
that non-designate so get rid of that
non-designated bit and say
um uh which are an important aspect of
our local heritage
okay
i would also consider putting in of
national importance
and of national employment yeah
absolutely
yeah and of national yeah fine
okay are we ready to uh vote on that now
memphis
no not quite okay yes
council should you want to see me thank
you in two
i think uh we should um mention
protected species
so um impacts on important ecological
um including um ecological assets
including protected species
thank you thank you tara and
and also chairman vibration
you and your vibration noise vibration
and disturbance
it's crucial to the seahorse though
isn't it i think that we're there now
oh just one thing we need to put in
about the national planning policy
framework section 170
chair if it's okay with your members i
think where it says
so contrary to policies s1d1 we should
add in there s
eight and blah blah blah blah the
national policy
uh plan and the guidance contained
within the national policy for actually
leave it at that the guidance contained
the national policy framework
because that would cover section 170.
okay
thank you uh so have i added s8
s8 to number two is that right chairman
not number one
number two yes eight yeah yes
thanks councillors thank you very much
mr lee
what do you what is your position on
this now
are you happy with our rewritten uh
video chairman i think members know my
professional advice on these matters
um right it's within as always in your
gifted term in the application as you
see fit
all right okay so we've um i think we
are probably there now so taro if we
could
uh call the role on this these two
reasons for refusal please okay
members so um i'll recall alphabetically
if you could just say fought against
or abstain please and starting with
councillor bamford
thank you tara i just want to say that
um
i'm going to abstain on this the reason
why is because
in agreeing this we are basically
just saying go to appeal
so i'm abstaining okay thank you how's
the passenger please
i'm against the application tara i've
phrased it that way cause i'm a little
confused
exactly what happened so county
passenger we're voting
for refusal for the two reasons that are
shown on the screen
and then i'm then i'm refusing you're in
favor you're for that
forward okay okay
um i'd rather rather appeal than
judicial review
so i'm for this recommendation thank you
uh councillor edwards four
whole
councillor hull no castle jarvis
i'm four thank you
council how was your vote please sorry
[Music]
lagoon please it was the leaders prefix
that her vote i i'd rather go to appeal
because it's the right thing to do for
the motion you cancel a maze
for councillor morris
thank you councillor shaunicy
four thank you councillor
[Music]
four thank you cancer schemes
four cancer stamp
mrs thompson against
the result of that vote is 14 4 one
against and three abstentions
thank you i have that and uh i do thank
uh
thank members it's been a very long and
uh
uh a long and uh
a grueling meeting i have to say a
gender item number 10
business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the chairman
to be urgent i have none
uh so members i do thank you uh for your
contributions decision
please question please chair
i'll have this i'll allow this one if
it's to the point christopher thank you
yep um i would just like to ask how much
the uh legal advice cost us
well i think that's a matter for another
meeting uh
i'm now going to draw this special
meeting to a close
at 5 10.
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum
and please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much
you